when you put three Jonas's together you
get this right yeah what's the other
one's name Nick Kyle no
Joe Nick and Kevin uh-huh all right
here's how the survey work you only went
over at 20 times he knows their
birthdays all right here we go here's
how the survey works we ask three
celebrities to complete a phrase our
first phrase was as president I made
sure my cabinet was full of Bill Clinton
said experts in their chosen field
Barack Obama said advisers I trusted to
tell me when I'm wrong
Donald Trump said people who were alive
and said yes you will you will never see
me Jessica Chastain said eat meat Angie
Herman said disrespect the flag Billy
Bush said again when I want to feel
better i watch Kristen Bell said the Sun
set over the ocean Fred Armisen said old
episodes of money Python Mike Pence said
the life slowly drained out of a small
bird's eye
don't knock until you tried it I miss I
miss the simplicity of Jeff Goldblum
said calling customer service and
getting to speak with a real person
Steve Martin said having a phone that
just makes phone calls
Larry King said all the continents being
connected as a single man you can ride a
Stegosaurus trip North America diarrea
without getting your car back I'm often
told I look like Elijah Wood said Daniel
Radcliffe Elizabeth Banks said Parker
Posey Steve Bannon said Robert Redford
with a shellfish allergy the biggest
criticism I get about my movies is Seth
Rogen said to juvenile Woody Allen said
not as funny as they used to be Nicolas
Cage said I preferred the book version
of diarrhea cop
when I got divorced I decided to break
it to my kids Courtney Cox said after
the holidays Jennifer Garner said with
my ex-husband Brad Pitt said in groups
of 20 and finally finally my favorite
pickup line is Joseph gordon-levitt said
may I buy you a drink
Mindy Kaling said want to hear a joke
Donald Trump said did you just fall from
heaven because I want to grab your
[Applause]
we have surveys
you